hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the first
meditation in his great work the
meditations on First Philosophy Rene
Descartes will introduce a figure that
has captivated reader's imagination ever
since and we typically talk about this
as the evil demon or the evil genius
both of which are perfectly fine English
translations for the the term that
Descartes himself uses the Moldy journey
in the French translation or in his
original Latin of course it's gained
'i'm [ __ ]
sorry so we've got some sort of very
powerful being who is also bad or evil
in some important way and now Descartes
doesn't introduce this because he really
believes that there is such a being if
you go on in the meditations you see
that he thinks that there is a God who
is all powerful and all good there is no
evil genius you might say well why is he
talking about this then and the reason
is because this provides him with a
hypothesis that he can use in order to
help himself doubt doubt is one of the
key parts of the Cartesian method and by
bringing in some sort of idea like this
an idea of some sort of evil be
a personal being who is intentionally
deceiving Descartes he can strip away a
lot of the beliefs that he has held and
still finds himself whether he likes it
or not holding with with some degree of
what we could call probability or
plausibility and dick Hurtz goal is to
get rid of all of those to suspend them
to put them to the side so he brings in
this hypothesis or like swinging to the
other extreme in things he brings in
this hypothesis so that he can rid
himself of those not because he actually
thinks that there's anything remotely
like what's depicted in the matrix or
the game or The Truman Show or any of
the movies that people often liken to
this sort of scenario and remember
Descartes is coming up with this idea in
the 17th century on his own and thinking
maybe the the everything that I'm
encountering could really be a product
of this so let's take a look at what
this being is like how dick Hart depicts
him and and he does it in meditation one
but also again in meditation too so
there's really two main traits that
occur in this one is he says that it's
it's very powerful right he says there's
a certain evil genius or demon no less
clever and deceptive than powerful who
employs all of his industry all of his
ability in order to deceive me
so whatever powers this being has he is
turning the full bore of it on to
Descartes he's he's sparing no expense
he's sparing no attention that's his
goal whatever you know you because why
why the hell would he care about that
well Descartes doesn't worry about that
so he's incredibly powerful as powerful
as we can imagine and he is also clever
Jose and
and deceptive homepure and he's trying
to deceive Pompeii Descartes so what
does he do
how does he deceive Descartes again
remember the card is using this as a
wedge to try to strip away all these old
beliefs at least for the moment so he
tricks Descartes into believing a whole
bunch of different things and we'll just
take the meditation one formulation we
can look at how it comes out in
meditation to in just a moment so he
says he uses all of his industry in
order to fool me and so I will think
that I will think to myself rather that
the sky the air the earth the external
world right a little bit later he'll say
all of these exterior things that we see
right so the external world as a whole
is being portrayed as an illusion or
hallucination or deception brought about
by this super powerful being who is
somehow putting these ideas into de
cartes mind that doesn't mean that there
isn't a world but Descartes can't say
that there actually is a world so that's
part of it that the world exists and
then if you think about de cartes
process in meditation one he's not just
talking about individual things that
he's not just talking about the world as
such but he talks about certain ranges
of our perceptions that could be turned
into imaginations so he also talks about
colors right colors you know maybe if
the world isn't what we think it is at
least there's colors right and we could
use those in an imaginary way to
reconstruct something or getting even
closer to what Descartes takes extension
to be about figures shapes you know
structures of things or sounds and he
could go on and on with with other
things maybe at least these exist or
maybe the evil genius is implanting
those in my mind maybe there's not only
no colors maybe there's no triangles
maybe there's no circles maybe none of
that action
exists and then Descartes goes on
further and says he also deceives me
into thinking that I have a body right
he says I will consider myself as not
having any hands any eyes any flesh any
blood not having any senses but
believing falsely to have all of these
things so you know our perception of our
body is something that's with us all the
time and we could add more and more to
that maybe I don't have the
proprioceptive you know capacities of
figuring out where I am right maybe I
don't have the pain that I feel when I
when I poked myself right maybe all of
that is simply illusions that are being
brought about by a consistent deception
of me and and Descartes is saying to
himself maybe the demon is doing that or
you know if not I don't actually need a
demon I can just decide for myself to
doubt all these things it just helps to
have somebody who I could you know sort
of blame it on you might say right and
so he says that what I'm gonna do here's
my resolution I'm going to take care and
here I'm translating rather loosely says
that's why Japan vegard Swan use them
all right I will I will take care I will
be attentive and then Swan user-mode
with very great care not to accept
anything into my beliefs that has any
falsity Oh Kundun félicité right and he
says that I will prepare my mind against
all of the ruses all of the tricks of
this great deceiver who as powerful and
as clever as he might be will not be
able to impose anything upon me so
notice that decart is not depicting this
evil demon as totally able to deceive
him
de Kurt says actually if I withdraw my
assent from all of these things I don't
let any of these things that I don't
know for certain in and I treat them all
as false I can keep myself from being
deceived no matter how powerful and how
clever this being is and I would like to
sort of conclude by talking about two
other very interesting metaphors that
Descartes uses Descartes is a master by
the way of images and metaphors for all
of the distrust that he often evinces of
them
he talks at the very end of meditation
one about being like a slave or servant
who is having pleasant dreams and
doesn't want to wake up from them even
though he realizes that their dreams
that their illusions and he doesn't want
to wake up from him because he knows
that his wake you know his awoken life
is not going to be very fun in
meditation too he begins by saying that
he is like a person who has fallen here
we go
he says it's like I had fallen into a
very deep body of water and I was so
surprised that I wasn't able to place
with any confidence my feet on the
bottom nor can I swim to hold myself
above and so doubt is is you know being
portrayed there in a way that you know
holds out the possibility maybe we won't
actually reach any foundation maybe
maybe if there is an evil demon maybe we
never arrive at the truth so what we see
here is the card is using this
hypothesis as a sort of linchpin to you
know pry away all of these deeply held
beliefs that it has Y attribute it to a
single being like this well Descartes
also has a preference for saying you
know we see this in other works as well
as this things that are created by one
person tend to be better
than those created by by many they're
more orderly so if one being is devoting
all of his attention to deceiving this
other one being you can expect that the
illusions would be create quite good but
you notice that again not only is this
just a hypothesis Descartes says even if
such a being did exist I would have the
resources to be able to combat his
illusions so that is what Descartes is
doing with this evil demon or evil
genius
you